with Mission Impossible rogue nation out
now let's take a look at 7 things you
probably didn't know about the 5th bell
in the super spy series although Tom
Cruise has a good deal of experience
stunt driving before filming the high
speed car and motorbike chases along
winding Moroccan roads he spent an
intensive 6 weeks training working with
stunt coordinator Wade Eastwood whose
speciality is car stunts crews learnt to
drift drive and according to Eastwood
the actor rode the BMW s1000 double our
sport bike at speeds of up to a hundred
miles an hour when Ethan Hunt dives into
an underwater facility to change your
security profile card the chamber where
he has to swap out the card is labeled
108 this is an Easter Egg for JJ Abrams
TV series lost were the number 108 or a
sequence of numbers which added up to
108 often appeared rogue nation is
produced by bad robot a production
company founded by Abrams who also
directed Mission Impossible 3 the name
of Swedish actress Rebecca Ferguson's
character Ilsa was inspired by a
character of the same name played by
another Swedish actress in a 1940's
movie that actress was Ingrid Bergman
and the movie was Casablanca which
starred Humphrey Bogart by the way not
so coincidentally part of rogue nation
was actually filmed in Casablanca
Morocco during Ferguson's first meeting
with director Chris McQuarrie and Tom
Cruise they compared Ilsa in Mission
Impossible to Ingrid Bergman and fellow
Swedish actress Greta Garbo in terms of
their Grace and the use of light and
shadows in the way they were filmed to
get ready for some especially dizzying
stunts Rebecca Ferguson spent over a
month training in Pilates explosive
running fight technique and firearms for
six hours a day six days a week her
training also included numerous 12-foot
practice drops in the stunt rehearsal
area before she tackled the real 75 foot
drop from the roof of the Vienna State
Opera House on her first day of filming
by the end of the shoe
Furguson had done that drop 40 times oh
and by the way she also had to overcome
her fear of heights and claustrophobia
to bring those stunts to life remember
the movies opening stunts which Tom
Cruise actually did himself hanging on
to the outside when Airbus a400m
military transport plane as it flew up
to 5,000 feet in the air well that scene
was shot at the RAF Wittering herb A's
in Cambridgeshire England a special rig
was built to attach the camera to the
outside of the plane and the movie
cinematographer operated it remotely
from inside the plane to capture
additional footage from a different
angle
they also filmed from a helicopter that
flew beside the plane as the airplane
was travelling up to 180 miles per hour
the force of the wind was so great
during filming that crews had to have
special contact lenses made to cover his
eyeball so he could keep his eyes open
and still protect them from engine fumes
and airborne debris Cruz gave director
Christopher McQuarrie strict
instructions not to cut once they
started filming unless he gave a signal
to do so by touching the top of his head
in the end crews did the stunt a total
of eight times to make sure they got all
the shots they needed to make the
movie's underwater heist seen as real as
possible
Tom Cruise trained intensively in
freediving which is basically diving
without breathing apparatus crews built
up to doing 40 metre free dive and could
actually hold his breath underwater for
around six minutes after training in
Florida and the Cayman Islands with
veteran athletes including free diving
expert Kirk krack the scene was filmed
in a tank measuring about 40 feet square
at leaves and studios in the UK that
added realism water movers from the
special effects Department were used in
the tank to make cruises hair move and
so he could swim against the current
however the force of the moving water
was so strong that they had to tether
crews to avoid him getting pushed
backwards cruises said that the dive
scene was the most physically
challenging part of the movie for him
and it took him significantly longer to
recover from than any
at the scene all those shooting a
Mission Impossible action scene can be
pretty intense Tom Cruise and Simon Pegg
still found time for fun on set while
they were filming a car chase scene in
Casablanca the two actors kept
themselves amused during long stretches
in the car in the scorching Moroccan
heat by playing pranks including
sneakily switching on each others car
seat heater and waiting to see how long
it took the other one to notice now let
me know in the comments below what crazy
stunts would you like to see Tom Cruise
do next in Mission Impossible 6 and
which is your favorite Mission
Impossible movie and why if you enjoyed
this video do please share it hit the
thumbs-up button and subscribe for more
things you didn't know as well as movie
reviews and interviews thanks for
watching yippee-ki-yay movie lovers